would you believe it if I said I missed
you know I need your help Matthew you're
the only person I can trust one
sweetheart you don't break into my house
and then talk to me about trust what do
you want from me
you fight better than anyone I know and
I have information the Yakuza never left
that's impossible I drove them out of
New York City no you didn't they're just
hibernated and watch you take out all of
their enemies
now New York is ripe for the taking if
we do this nobody dies do you understand
[Music]
hungry every time I walk up those stairs
I wonder today's the day you're dead in
your living life there are horrible
things happening in the city I'm done
apologizing to you for who I am
the city needs me this isn't your city
anymore
my way isn't working what if that never
happened
festival has begun Matthew there's
nothing we can't fight their I'm cold
the hand you cannot stop what we have
started the rising is coming
you've been working out by the way I
appreciate
hey youtubers it's Charlie so daredevil
season two trailer we finally get to see
electron action this is like the Electra
version of the trailer so let's do a
breakdown in the really big news is
Marvel just confirmed that finn jones
from Game of Thrones the guy who plays
Loras is going to be Danny rant aka iron
fist and they just announced the casting
so they're probably not going to shoot
that series till later this year but as
they ramp up for daredevil season to
just expect them to make more
announcements about iron fist season one
which will probably end up seeing in
2017 it is going to be bad freaking ass
but on to daredevil stuff unlike the
last trailer we also learn a little bit
about what the story is going to be the
handler back in a big way that's kind of
what i thought was going to be the case
after last season they just teased the
hand they were going to bring in the
electric character electra is part of
the hand in the comics and stick is the
one in the trailer who's like their name
is the hand he is part of the chaste
they're like the diametric opposite of
the hand they exist in this constant
state of war between dark and light and
how fitting that once they get to the
hand part of the trailer they talk about
the rising and there's this giant hole
in the ground that's kind of a follow-up
to the black sky stuff from last season
who I think is an inhuman I think they
were using it in human with a
combination of magic to raise a demon I
don't know how close are going to stick
to the hands origin story in the comics
they might change a few things but
within the hand they start serving
someone known as the Beast which gives
them their dark magic so that might be
who they're trying to raise during
season to last season daredevil defeated
Nobu who was kind of like the leader
they had one of the leaders of the hand
just like any comic book organization
there have been several leaders
daredevil even took control of the hand
himself for a brief period in the comics
but I'm wondering if this character here
is kagiri one of the big leaders of the
hand or it could be a resurrected Nobu
in the comics they do have the power to
stave off mortal wounds so even if you
were to kill one of them they could
still come back because of their dark
magic so they might weave that into this
like oh my god I thought I killed you
last season there was a big battle
between the hand and the Yakuza but in
the comics it was actually orchestrated
by Sabretooth not expecting to see
Sabretooth pop up during daredevil
anytime soon but just in general it
seems like season 2 daredevil realizes
that his methods aren't working people
keep getting back up in the last trailer
the punisher was like I hit him so that
they don't get back up so if daredevil
reconnect with Elektra because Electra
is his college girlfriend that foggy was
talking about during season one they
have history together in a way that
Punisher and daredevil don't their
methods tend to be a little more
permanent that's why Daredevils like if
we do this we're not killing anyone they
will probably tempt him in the biblical
sense remember this is daredevil
Catholicism is a big part of the
character so expect a lot of
heavy-handed religious themes throughout
not a whole lot of Punisher in the
trailer we do see him taking a couple
villains down mostly this is Electra in
the way they've talked about her during
daredevil season two is that she's kind
of like the best bad girlfriend that
Matt ever had but all the words that
have been used to describe her are bad
girlfriend so it's like a really bad
relationship that just completely twists
daredevil round one of the really
awesome things about their relationship
in the comics though is that Daredevils
ability to tell whether or not people
are lying like he uses their heart be he
just senses it so he knows whether or
not you're telling the truth it doesn't
work on Electra so whatever
assassination mission that has brought
Electra to New York she's probably co-op
daredevil services he'll go dark because
she's kind of like forbidden fruit so
she'll be able to get him to do things
that he doesn't want to do forbidden
fruit remember heavy-handed religious
themes in Punisher will seemingly solve
the problem of fighting the war in a way
that actually makes headway because the
big question that Matt is asking himself
the trailer is it you know do my methods
still work am I still relevant am I
actually making good on anything and yes
I know foggy picks his costume up he has
the red eyelids looking at the costume
it seems like they upgrade it just a
little bit remember when he got at the
end of season one the idea was it's not
finished yet but he put it on anyway
because he needed the armor so season 2
comes maybe we'll see an evolution of
that but remember daredevil tends to be
crime drama so any of the magical
elements probably won't service till
later in the series it still plays it
relatively real world I don't think
they'll go full-blown magic until we get
to iron fist even when we get to the
Luke Cage series it's going to be good
old-fashioned crime drama and I'm
curious to see which of those other
characters pop up during daredevil
season 2 they greenlit Jessica Jones
season 2 we might see one or two of
those characters in the way daredevil
characters showed up during Jessica
Jones it wasn't what you would call a
direct crossover so I'm wondering how
long it's going to be before we actually
see Heroes for Hire or let you know like
the actual main characters appear on
screen together let me know in the
comments
what do you think about the electric
character I know Punisher is gonna be
awesome i'm actually i'm really excited
it's been so long since that terrible
Electra movie I feel like most people
have largely forgotten it but if you
really want to punish yourself just use
as many puns as possible and by all
means go back and re-watch it I don't
think I've watched the Ben Affleck
daredevil since the year it was released
it's been that long what's going to
happen tonight is is probably gonna be
one of the most badass episodes of
legends of tomorrow I have a special
video shoot that I'm making with a
couple of my friends so my legends video
might post a little bit later than
normal but it'll still post tonight
Connor Hawke Deathstroke old Oliver
Queen be sure to check it out why use
wait for me to post that video i just
did a spider-man civil war video you can
click here for that and you can click
here for all my other daredevil season 2
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you